-Hey, guys, we're here
at McNally Jackson bookstore
in midtown Manhattan, and we're
about to surprise some people
who think that they're part
of a promotional campaign
for Michelle Obama's new book,
"The Light We Carry."
They're going to press a button
to hear inspirational quotes
from the former First Lady,
Michelle Obama.
But what they don't know is
that the real Michelle Obama
will be reading them
the quotes live.
-That is me.
-Ready?
-Let's do this.
♪♪
-I was going to
get this one, too.
-Please press the button.
♪♪
Please press the button to hear
an inspirational quote
from Michelle O.
-We practice our faith
in the smallest of ways.
With it, we are saying, "I can."
We are saying "I care."
-Simon says, touch your head.
Simon says,
touch your shoulders.
Press the button.
Simon didn't say.
Now pose for a picture.
Three, two, one.
Turn around.
-Smile, ladies.
-[ Gasps ]
-Turn around, please.
-Simon says.
-Oh, my gosh!
-Smile.
-So nice to meet you.
-Oh, my gosh!
-Hi. I'm Jimmy.
-Press the button.
-We practice our faith
in the smallest of ways.
With it, we are saying, "I can."
We are saying, "I care."
-Simon says touch your head.
Simon says scream.
-[ Screams ]
-Louder.
-Simon didn't say
that last one.
-But Michelle Obama did.
-You lose.
But maybe you didn't lose.
-Oh, my God!
Oh, my God!
Wow!
-Because my mother
had faith in me,
I had faith in me, too.
-Mother's Day is coming up.
What are you getting
your mother?
-Let's see.
-You can pick up
a few books right now.
-Please buy my book.
Pretty please?
-"Pretty please
with sugar on top."
-With sugar on top?
-Please grab a book and look.
-Are you ready?
-Oh, my God!
-It's Michelle Obama.
-Buy my book.
Tools evolve over time.
And speaking of time,
it's time to dance.
-Oh.
-Show us your best moves.
Go.
Drop it low.
To the floor.
Down lower.
Go, go, go, go.
-Now pose for a picture.
Three, two...
-Go.
-[ Screams ] Oh, my God!
Oh, my God!
-You've got some great moves.
-Oh, my God!
-Thank you just for going
through this entire journey
with grace.
That's what you are.
And to have the opportunity
to say that to you, thank you.
-Oh, sweetie,
that means everything.
It means everything to me.
-Ahhh!
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪